what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some pretty big news
about Deadpool 3 and about Spider-Man 4
specifically in regards to Tom Holland's
new contract but also about John Watts
and Zendaya as well and as far as
Deadpool 3 is concerned it looks like
some of our predictions were correct and
it looks like fans could be getting the
story that a lot of us actually wanted
and not to mention recently Hugh Jackman
has opened up about him returning as
Wolverine so we'll talk about that in
this video as well also for the G fuel
fans great news my code has been
permanently moved to 20 off it's now 20
off all the time unless I tell you it's
actually more than 20 off like 30 or 40
off which will happen sometimes so now
you can use my code to get the awesome
Marvel collectors items from Thor doctor
strange and the Multiverse of Madness
all of the Spider-Man ones and also not
to mention any of their other cool
flavors like the boys or Naruto and of
course they come come in cans they come
in powders they also have sparkling
hydration bottles as well so if you're a
big energy drink junkie like me you can
use my code Cosmic for 20 off on
gfuel.com so we've been talking a lot
about Spider-Man and his contract
recently not only with Spider-Man the
character and the MCU but also Tom
Holland as well so let's talk about that
first because I know everybody wants to
know what's going on now recently it's
actually been revealed that the MCU
Spider-Man Tom Holland Spider-Man is
going to be an across the spider-verse
we don't know if it's actually going to
be voiced by Tom Holland but clearly
there are things in the works here for
Spider-Man and Tom Holland himself and
today we have a new report to go over
coming from the account Tom Smith who
has been right about some leaks in the
past and yesterday he tweeted Tom
Holland's Spider-Man 4 is on The Fast
Track Holland is signed but one thing
that needs to be settled is the director
watts is wanted back but he experienced
superhero burnout and dropped out a
Fantastic Four for a reason then Zendaya
is also wanted back hashtag Spider-Man
and he continues to say in the thread
the goal is to film in 2023 for a summer
2024 release that's already been
reported by mycosmiccircus.com Sony's
been working on the story and script for
this film since no way home released so
as soon as they lock in a director it
should be ready to film now we're gonna
go over the whole thread and then talk
about it but as far as this particular
part is concerned this is true not too
long after Spider-Man no way home
released maybe a week maybe two Marvel
Studios president Kevin feige and Sony
executive producer Amy Pascal came out
together and stated that they have
already begun working on the next
Spider-Man movie Spider-Man 4 and they
specifically said that they were
specifically telling us this so fans
didn't have to worry about Spider-Man no
longer being in the MCU but we could
have peace of mind knowing Spider-Man is
indeed going to be returning to the MCU
for yet another film so that part is
true it has been confirmed for a while
now that we are going going to be
getting a Spider-Man 4 and they have
already begun to work on it when they
stated that which was almost a year ago
so things have been moving for
Spider-Man 4 for a pretty long time now
but let's continue this thread he
continues to say please note that it is
Sony that have the power to announce the
film Kevin feige Marvel Studios do not
pick the date you will get a spidey
announcement at a Sony present event and
this is accurate this is what we've been
talking about for a while now I
mentioned this part because CC XP is
right around the corner we should not
expect a Spider-Man announcement because
Sony is actually not attending ccxp they
have backed out now it is said that
they've backed out due to some
scheduling conflicts due to some
projects been moving around so it is
possible that we could be getting an
announcement pretty soon they're just
trying to get everything together for it
but the thread ends with him saying I
think this was reported about a year ago
but one idea early in development was to
have Miles Morales living in Peter
Parker's apartment complex I don't know
if that stayed in the later drafts but
that is literally the only thing I've
heard about the plot of Spider-Man 4 LOL
now I'm not sure who Tom's source is I
know he's posted things in the past but
most of this sounds like it's probably
pretty accurate now of course they're
going to want Zendaya to come back she's
one of the biggest actresses in the
world plus not to mention her
relationship with Tom Holland I'm
assuming she'll want to come back to
work with him again little awkward if
she didn't but just because her Ned at
the end of Spider-Man no way home forgot
everything about Peter Parker doesn't
mean that she's going to come back I'm
still convinced that the spell is going
to be undone in some way shape or form
or Peter is simply going to tell MJ
everything that happened and she'll
somehow remember so I don't doubt that
MJ is going to return however I do doubt
John Watts returning I do not think John
Watts is going to be returning to the
MCU to direct anything anytime soon he
was originally set to direct the
Fantastic Four film which is a very very
huge deal and a project extremely close
to Kevin feige's Heart Kevin feige had
trusted him to direct that film but he
backed out because of superhero fatigue
he directed all three Spider-Man
homecoming Trilogy movies and plus not
to mention Spider-Man no way home was
probably extremely stressful for him
trying to keep all of the secrets and
direct amazing actors and bring all
three Spider-Man on the screen for the
very first time so for him to direct
that trilogy plus not to mention one of
the biggest superhero movies of all time
and then back out of another superhero
film that could have been one of the
biggest movies of all time as well
that's pretty big so I do not believe
he's coming back but as far as Miles
Morales is concerned I think that if
this is truly the last Trilogy for Tom
Holland Spider-Man Miles Morales is the
next best move he was already teased in
Spider-Man homecoming we met Prowler his
uncle who said he has a nephew which
confirmed that a Miles Morales does
exist in the MCU somewhere actually not
too far where Peter Parker lives and now
Peter Parker has moved into a new
apartment complex because well one he
doesn't really have anybody to take care
of him anymore there's no more Aunt May
no more Iron Man and happy doesn't have
any idea who he is but two he could have
probably used some Avengers connections
to get somewhat of a place but he has to
be in his own small run-down place like
we've seen him do many many times in the
comics so he can actually grow as a
character and be out on his own and the
idea of having Miles live in the same
apartment complex of him I think is
actually pretty cool either that or we
could go down the road of them
volunteering at Feast which would make
sense for Peter Parker to do because of
Aunt May so it seems like things are
seemingly set for Spider-Man 4 it looks
like Tom Holland has officially signed
on to do more films rumor has it that
the contract was for six more films
three Spider-Man films and three team-up
films so get ready for a lot more
Spider-Man in the MCU and of course like
I mentioned Deadpool now today's news
about Deadpool is pretty exciting The
Insider account who has been extremely
accurate about all the leaks she's
posted before my time to shine hello has
tweeted out Deadpool kills the fox
universe and she added Robert lifeld the
create creator of Deadpool this has been
rumored to be the story of Deadpool 3
for a while now but it looks like she
has heard some inside information about
what the movie is at least going to
contain we know that Deadpool will start
off in the fox universe but somehow make
his way to the MCU we also know that the
TVA and Mobius is going to be after him
and now it seems like we pretty much
have a confirmation that he's going to
kill the old Fox Universe now this could
be done in many different ways one he
could simply go through the universe
with Wolverine killing a bunch of
different characters and even if this
isn't the whole plot of the movie I'm
sure we're going to see some of this at
least but what actually makes more sense
is that Deadpool and Wolverine end up
causing an incursion and the fox
universe is the universe that gets
destroyed this will tie in deadpool with
the TVA and tie in deadpool with
Avengers Secret Wars which is going to
be all about incursions but also keep in
mind that Ryan Reynolds mentioned that
Deadpool 3 is going to be about a road
trip with Deadpool and Wolverine
rashamon style basically a road trip
where each person recalls it a little
bit differently and I've mentioned this
before but they're probably going to
kill a lot of people but Deadpool's
going to see it very differently than
Wolverine Deadpool will probably make it
seem like they had no choice when
Wolverine will probably say that
Deadpool instigated it all so this could
very much lead to the destruction of the
fox Universe in one way or another I
think it's probably going to be a
combination of both but one thing is for
sure we are super excited to see
Deadpool and Wolverine together again
Hugh Jackman returned as his iconic
Wolverine and recently he has mentioned
that he thought he was going to retire
after Logan he never thought he was
going to play Wolverine again until
Deadpool 3 was announced it wasn't even
Ryan Reynolds trying to convince him to
return Hugh Jackman heard about Deadpool
3 and wanted to be in it this is what he
has recently said in an interview with
deadline.com so Hugh Jackman is
returning because he wants to which
means you know he's going to do an
incredible job as if we all had any
doubt at all so awesome Spider-Man and
Deadpool 3 News let me know how excited
you are about both of these projects in
the comments down below and don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf